hello everyone and welcome to a most
remarkable game from round one of the
coup de huaah rapid n blitz tournament
it's French for Ivory Coast or or at
least it should be I'm sorry I don't
speak French so I don't know if I
pronounced that properly but it's again
between wagons crossing inversely so
it's really a really really a remarkable
game I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it but
before that I have a short announcement
as you can see in the top left corner it
can be a bit confusing if you don't know
what's this all about it says join our
chests manga now a friend and I decided
to start creating a chest manga or so
maybe it's a comic I don't know the
difference between a comic and the manga
probably just this one is more of a
Western you know thing and the other one
just maybe a Japanese type of
entertainment maybe it's a difference in
drawing work but doesn't really matter
and he's still brushing up you know
honing his drawing skills and whatnot
and while he's doing so we would like to
have something to practice with so I was
thinking if you're feeling creative or
if you have some sort of a nice story if
you were interested in starting a monk
or something like that if well it maybe
you already have it written maybe you
would like to write it I will put a link
in the description below it will be an
email a newly created email you can use
it to send us at this either an idea or
it could be already an entire script or
maybe just a few sentences about what
what it could be it could be pretty much
anything it could be a story about a I
don't know person playing chess but
something happens to him it could be a
drama it could be you know maybe maybe
you're a Demon Slayer by night and
brushing up on your endgame skills by
day really really anything and if you're
interested in that do join us and you
know we will mostly be using it as
practice for when we want to do start
releasing it but if you know if it's a
great idea maybe it will even stick and
of course then you you are immediately a
part of the team so maybe if I don't
know if you're interested in that do
check out do check it out and do do send
us your ideas so that being said let's
return to this very nice game like we
said the coup de huaah
Rico's tournament in Abidjan Magnus
Carlsen versus Wesley so it's the first
part of the 2019 Grantchester
and well this year it happens on more
continents than the previous year they
are also coming one part of the
Grantchester is also being played in
Croatia through June and July so it will
be pretty cool to see all of these well
elite players come to my to my small
country of Croatia and yeah I think it's
gonna be really awesome and the prize
fund for the entire event here is a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars or
not not for the entire one I believe for
the for the rapid part I'm not sure
about the Blitz one but we're first
gonna cover the rapid so it's a three
games of rapid every day the rapid
section goes for three days the time
control is 25 minutes per player no
increment but there is a delay of 10
seconds before every move starting from
1 so you can basically play an entire
game without losing any time if you make
every move under 10 seconds which is you
know not often the case but yeah yeah I
just wanted to share that and we do have
some photos compliments of Leonardo tiss
the official photographer of the
Grantchester 2019 so here they are there
you have it
Wesley so and magnus carlsen with a
gentleman making the first move I do not
recognize the gentleman but if any of
you do I welcome you to share in the
comments so we can all increase our
wealth vast knowledge then we have a
very nice photo of Carlson shaking the
gentleman's hand here also you can see
cross and rocking his is Clark a water
really I've tried it it's it's actually
a very nice water then we have there
also I'm not a nice photo Wesley from
behind magnets there and then we see
Maurice Ashley on the left looking
smooth as always and lastly but not
leastly there we have Carson and Wesley
it's still in the opening and there you
have it with the nice colorful orange
and green letters could the wah wrap in
a blitz tournament and all of the
players we're gonna talk about all the
players and the standings after we show
a couple of games but you know we're
gonna go back to that so this was a bit
of a longer intro but it is the first
game in this tournament so I
you don't mind now without further ado
let's check out the game Carson has the
white pieces and he opens with c4 and
he's been opening with c4 a lot of his
games lately and with with great results
with Easton's by Wesley sorry about that
the AG in court the defense the
Carlson's English with Knight to c3 d5
by Wesley and now Carlson takes this
opportunity to take of course the game
into the known waters of the Queens
gambit declined with a knight to f6 and
C capture Sun d5 like capablanca cross
him also a fan of the early capture on
d5 we have Knight captures efore now
kicking away the knight now you could go
back would not be six but it's
considered better to just capture on c3
be captures and now c5 by Wesley we have
rook to be one the similar structure
like the groom fell defense but the the
bishop will not be fin cathode on g7
after Carlson's rook to be one Wesley
just goes to Bishop to e7
we have Knight to f3 by Carlsen castles
with Bishop to e2 by crossing and now b6
the bishop will be developed to this b7
Square to assume this long diagonal we
have castles by Carlsen Bishop to b7 and
here this position has already been
reached in the last year's game between
young Gustafson and Kristoff iyslah
where Gustafson won the game also he
played Queen to d3
but Iowa continued would see captures on
d4 but here was the goes 9b d7 it's a
new move and now we have a completely
new game cousin continues development
with rook to e1 the pawn is about to be
a be attacked with Knight f6 so you do
have to prepare to defend it we have
looked the c8 the C file will become
open at one point so you want to develop
rooks to open files and now cousins the
last piece that's undeveloped is this
bishop and c1 you want to develop it to
the most active squared and that is the
f4 square where the bishop is most
active with Knight to f6 now pressuring
d4 pawn as the bishop and Knight are
attacking it and now bushes the d1 the
rook is also now defending the pawn with
nice to h5 saying the Carlsen
I want this diagonal for my queen you
have to move the bishop or you will lose
the bishop pair cousin says alright I'm
not giving you the bishop pair we
the trip to d2 and now Queen to c7
Wesley increases the pressure along the
C file and now the queen is also on this
very nice diagonal with Knight to g5 by
crossing saying you either have to weak
in your position or you have to give up
the bishop pair or I'm just gonna have a
nice night on g5 it's it's your call
basically and Wesley says no thank you
I'm gonna go Knight a four-block your
Bishop the defense of the night here and
now it's you who can give up the bishop
pair but of course Carlson is not
interested in giving up the bishop pair
Queen to g3 defending the knight and now
we have Knight back to g6 by Wesley
offering the Queen trade and here it's
one of the rare cases where Coulson
doesn't immediately jump at the chance
of a Queen trade
he plays Queen to g4 he wants to go h4
h5 basically saying my position is
better my pieces are more active they're
controlling more squares the Queen trade
will not I mean even though it's
possible
Magnus thinks that he should go for
activity in this game and and keep the
Queen's on the board here as you don't
want to allow this with Bishop captures
and g5 Wesley gives up the bishop pair
but by doing so he also wins the pawn so
it's it will be very interesting to see
what's Cousins compensation for the pawn
with Bishop captures Bishop captures and
now comes C captures on d4 see captors
on d4 and now well it's easier to see if
we just go back to moves before this
capture note that when Carson played
Bishop to d1 the rooks are no longer
connected and this rook and E 1 will
become undefended so this is the the
idea you have to see and then it's clear
how to win a pawn just Bishop captures
like Wesley played Bishop captures
captures captures and now you see that
the rook on e1 is unguarded Queen to c3
with a double attack the rook and the
pond or now and price so you do have to
defend it Bishop to b3 once again cross
and connects rooks and now Queen
captures on d4 so what Carson crossings
compensation for the pawn seems like
blacks position is great the rook is on
an open C file this Arturo can be
developed to d8 the bishop assumes this
beautiful diagonal the knight is well it
would be better maybe somewhere on f6
but but it's it's a good night
so what's Coulson's compensation for the
phone well first rugby to be one just
winning the D file and forcing the Queen
to move with Queen to e5 and the now
comes h4 cousin hopes to push h5 to kick
the night away Wesley of course doesn't
allow it first h6 kicking the bishop
back will push up the c1 and now not
allowing h5 Wesley pushes h5 himself so
h5 and now you can see that Carson can't
really move the Queen because well he
can't very well give up yet another
point Knight captures on f4 would be
well would be great for black so if your
cousin says I don't mind being down upon
Queen to g5 now we trade Queens and okay
Queen captures with pawn captain sorry
Bishop captures on g5 now controlling
the d8 square so rook cannot be
developed there that's excellent
compensation for the moment f6 is not
possible as the e6 pawn will hang with
check so rook to c7 Wesley prepares the
double-up rooks here and now comes f4
and it's a super interesting move
because it basically offers Wesley to
play f6 and trap the bishop but for the
moment it's not possible as the e6 pawn
still hangs and you do want to prevent
it because f5 is a threat if f5 was to
be played then the knight would have to
go all the way to h8 so first
Wesley stops it with Bishop to c8 rook
to e8 would have been better just
freeing up the f8 square for the knight
but okay our first he goes worship the
ciock now preventing f5 but now cross
and just goes rip the c1 he takes this
little opportunity where Wesley is not
able to double rooks here to take
control of the C file and now if you
capture then it doesn't matter that
Carlson is down upon he's gonna go roof
to c7 his position is gonna be much
better so here we have looked a b7 a
really awkward place for the rook not
allowing cross in this rook lift would
rook to c7 and well for the moment
Wesley's pieces aren't all that greatly
coordinated rook the sea 3 by Carlsen he
is preparing rook to c1 and for the
moment f6 still not possible it seems
like it traps the bishop but it really
doesn't
because of Route captures in c8 rook
captures and our Bishop captures an e6
Czech wins the rook King f8 Bishop
captures now you have to deal with the
rook and now even Bishop f5 attacking
the knight 97 and here you would have to
go there should be six captures captures
and you would go into this end game
where it's actually Carson who's up a
pawn but with a much better position so
Wesley is not interested in this first
King to h7 if f6 is now played Bishop
captures here will not be happening with
Czech so rook eat the c1 still not
allowing f6 as a route captures Bishop
would happen Bishop to d7 and now even
rook to c7 still not possible to play f6
rook captures rook captures going for
the bishop here and here if you move the
bishop then he v happens and you're
never going to push f6 f6 now loses to
pawn captures and the G pawn is pinned
of course you cannot capture it so after
rook captures on c7 with f6 by Wesley
finally deciding to to do it if he
doesn't do it now he's not going to do
it ever with rook captures on b7 pawn
captures on g5 f captors and g5 and now
Knight captures on h4 so now you see
after all is said and done
of course Bishop captures only 6 the
material on the board is equal but
crosses position is well it seems to be
much better and it's not all that easy
to decide how to play this position with
black as the night doesn't really have
all that many squares you can't go here
you can't go here you can go here and of
course if you go here to bring the right
back into the game just Bishop f5 wins
the game
you're can't unpin here if you're on pin
you lose the night you can go rook f6
the pawn covers the f6 square next move
you're just gonna go rogue d6 and take
the knight so King to g6 Wesley wants to
grab the g5 pawn here rook captures on a
7 by Carlsen King captures and now rook
captures on g7 of course we check King
to have sex with a double attack but of
course the roof to gh takes takes takes
care of everything and here the best
course of action for black would be just
to capture and after Bishop captures
King Aoife not king g5
but it's still very hard to play the
game you have to bring the night into
the game this way if you go king e5 you
can even lose the game instantly with
Bishop here because the bishop h7 traps
the night you can see that the knight
now can't go anywhere and well once once
you can go king of six and bring the
knight back into the game but once the
bishop captures the knight then it is
just three points to two points of
course a completely winning endgame here
Wesley went for a different line he
played Knight to g6 immediately but now
it's an even clearer when it's really a
beautiful simple win for white feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
it this well simple but but the deadly
move for white I'll give you a couple of
seconds is usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent finder of simple yet
deadly winning moves and for those who
just want to enjoyed show rook captures
and on a fate would check that's the
point you have to recapture the rook
Knight captures and now of course the
move you have to find Bishop f5 you all
know this famous relationship between a
bishop and a knight when they are two
squares apart then the bishop controls
all of the squares that the knight can
jump to and vice versa of course if the
position is other way around so here
black will never be able to introduce
the knight back into the game if he does
whenever he plays the night anywhere
even phrases for a bishop then of course
we enter again into this King and pawn
endgame whatever let's say white just
starts bringing the King into the game
and let's say Knight goes here captures
captures and of course now the the end
game is completely winning for white but
yeah after this Knight to g6 cross and
simply played this Bishop to f5 move and
it was in this position that Wesley so
resigned the game so an excellent
victory for Magnus in this round one of
the of the coup de huaah rapid
tournament we're gonna cover up a few
more games and I'm leaving my hometown
today as I'm going to mock Rosco for for
a short chess tournament and I don't
know if how many games will I be able to
cover as they are playing so many games
it's a rapid tournament three games
every day but I'm bringing my laptop
with me so I will try to cover as many
as possible yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like I would like to thank Julien you
subs are they omen Mortazavi I've been
the big understand Robert Butler and
Alessandra inocente for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing this could wha rapid
tournament and maybe if I grab the time
also simultaneous continuing the
capablanca saga and of course do check
out the chess manga I mentioned or
rather maybe check out the option of
joining us you know creating it so
that's it thank you all I will see soon
heavily have an excellent rest of your
day